execution the carrying out and putting
into effect
of a plan order or course of action
putting it into effect execution
i put it into effect
a course of action not thinking this is
not a board meeting
this is not what do you all think
this is not let's get buy-in from our
staff
and make sure everyone's happy with it
i never get buy-in
i get my buy-in hey do i want to do this
event do i want to buy this piece of
real estate number one question i'm
asking myself all the time do i want to
do this
do i want to buy this piece of real
estate
right do i want to be in this if not
bail out of it if so lean into it
and if i'm a lean into it that means
time and money it always will mean if
you're taking notes it will always mean
time and money never an idea
it's never a motivational speech it's
always time and money where your time
and your money goes
you
will
follow
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how to
stop procrastinating and being lazy
enjoy
rule number two start doing small things
with mel robbins this is a question from
vicki vicki writes i'm trying to become
a fashion and beauty blogger and mer and
earn money from it full time but i have
some kind of mental block and
procrastination problem
when it comes to actually pushing myself
to do anything related to that goal
this is this is something that we hear
about
all the time
that you have this huge goal
yet you cannot seem to push through the
mental block that you have something
that you want to do full time but you
can't seem to beat procrastination this
is something that we see over and over
and over again and it's this idea that
you don't ever start
you stay trapped in your head and if you
feel paralyzed if you've been spinning
the same ideas over and over and over
again
then you know what i'm talking about
you see
many of you are thinking way too big
you're attaching way too much pressure
on the things that you're interested in
until you start
blogging about fashion you won't even
know if you like it so thinking that you
have a dream about doing it and thinking
that you have this grand plan that
you're going to do it full time it is a
complete and utter waste of your time to
be dreaming that big and let me tell you
why because oftentimes if you're the
kind of person like vicky that's getting
trapped up here the bigness of what
you're thinking about is what's stopping
you what i want you to do if you're in
vicky's situation is i want you to stop
dreaming and i want you to just start
doing small things i want you to go back
to curiosity and less into crushing your
big goals the thing about life and
business and success is that you have to
be willing to start and for people that
procrastinate starting is the hardest
part for people that worry for people
that think too big starting is the
hardest part folks that study
procrastination talk about the fact that
the only way to beat procrastination is
to create what they call a starting
ritual which is a way to push yourself
to get started because all the research
shows that if we can push you to get
started on something you'll likely keep
going so vicky the only way to get out
of the mental trap is to stop
thinking
and actually start doing it and maybe
thinking that this is going to be your
full-time employment that's the wrong
way to go about it i want you to
literally
just commit to writing some sort of blog
about fashion every day for a week
that's it don't think about full time
don't think about the bigness of it
actually start doing it you may discover
you don't like it for crying out loud
but you're never ever ever going to
advance if you continue up here how do
you force yourself to do it well you can
use the five second rule for that you
can wake up in the morning and say today
i'm committing to making small progress
on this thing i'm curious about which is
fashion blogging you can find time when
you're going to sit down and then the
second that it's time to do it five four
three two one and start writing here's
what you can expect to experience if
you're somebody like vicky who has
trouble getting out of the thinking loop
the second that it's time to actually
move from thought to action you will
become a first class [ __ ] you will
feel resistance you will struggle with
what you're going to write you will
start to feel like it needs to be
perfect you're going to come up with
excuses you're going to talk yourself
out of it why
well because you're used to thinking and
now you're asking yourself to do
why am i explaining what you should
expect the reason why i'm explaining
what you should expect is because it's
normal to feel those things it's normal
to feel scared it's normal to feel like
you don't want to do it it's normal to
think about doing it perfect
letting those things stop you is a
choice
so
let me recap you're the kind of person
like vicky that's got all these big ass
dreams but you can't get out of your
thinking loops you can't stop
procrastinating you can't stop thinking
about it you get overwhelmed and so you
do nothing the only solution is micro
action that's it i don't want to hear
[ __ ] about your big goals in fact for
everybody out there i don't hear about
your dreams and your goals until you're
actually taking the actions every day
for a couple weeks straight
you don't get to talk about your dreams
until you can prove that you wake up and
every single damn day you push yourself
to take one small action forward if you
can do that consistently for a month
then you can start talking about your
dreams then you can start talking about
how you make money at it then you can
start talking about how you build skill
around it but until you can actually get
your ass out of bed and make the
commitment to yourself to do the actions
required to
become a blogger or to be a vlogger not
become to be a blogger to be somebody
that's in the restaurant business
you're just all talk rule number three
discover who you are with russell
brunson how many of you guys are
procrastinating too long and you know
that so if you have a problem and you're
busy watching youtube videos how do you
beat procrastination so i'm actually
gonna do this one out okay so this right
here this is um your computer
all right and on your computer there's
tons of stuff happening right you've got
your in fact i'm gonna make a little
laptop you'll see my mad drawing skills
i'm actually really bad at doodling
there you go there's your laptop and
you're typing away and there's all these
things happening right there's there's
youtube and there's uh instagram and
there's facebook in fact most you guys
are watching this on one of these
platforms right now i guarantee and so
you're probably in this procrastination
mode where you're not focusing on just
um just getting stuff done and so for me
what i what i have to do is a lot of is
comes back to like how you structure
your day and how you figure um some of
those things out but if you want to stop
procrastinating um
there's a couple things one of the one
of the reasons why entrepreneurs
procrastinate i learned this from um
from dan sullivan um he talked about i'm
gonna move my books over here so we
talked about most of us entrepreneurs
right we have
we have uh this vision of this thing we
wanna accomplish right so here's your
vision
and you're like i wanna do that i wanna
serve these people i wanna create this
product i wanna make money doing what
you have this vision we're trying to go
right and here is you over here and you
see this vision and you're like this is
how what i have to go and so you start
on this path you start walking towards
your vision then something happens where
you get stuck right where you're trying
to learn something new that you don't
understand and you're like ah and you
get stuck and then what happens i don't
know about you but i've written now a
couple books and i get this all the time
i read my books where i'm i'm like i'm
writing and there's like pain associated
and my brain's like i need to do
anything except for the painful thing
that's over here so you start trying to
figure out other things to do and what
happens is then you start shifting to
this mode of procrastination
and usually this this uh this detour
happens you're trying to figure out how
do i do something right you're like how
do i do this thing you start researching
then you're listening to podcasts and
you're reading a book and another thing
another thing another thing you're going
searching youtube and then you listen to
the video that shows you how to then you
like see all the cute girls in the video
there she watched those then you're off
on this tangent and then you're and next
thing you know it's like three days
later right how many guys that happened
for more than once okay and so what dan
sullivan talked about so look if you
want to get to your vision you can't
keep procrastinating that's what it says
right here procrastinating
um because the reason the thing that
causes procrastination is how like how
do i
how do i how do i do this thing you see
what you have to start shifting your
focus to is instead of like how do i do
is is this question of who
who already knows how to do the thing
i'm trying to get done right so for me
when i was building click funnels i
could have been like all right first
step i need to code software called
click funnels right and i would have sat
down and i would like okay i need a
programming book and i'm gonna read
programming i'm gonna learn ruby on
rails i can learn javascript i can learn
all these things and i would have been
procrastinating for forever because i'm
not smart enough to be a programmer
right or i step back i said who do i
know who actually knows how to execute
on this already and i met my partner
todd dickerson who's the dude who built
click funnels initially and todd was who
already knew how to do it so i'd have to
learn how to do programming i just found
todd who's the who and he went and
started programming it and got us closer
to the vision right and that's like okay
i need to design a sales letter now i'm
not a designer so i needed somebody to
help with that and i needed and instead
of me trying to figure out how to do
like how to use photoshop how to use um
uh facebook ads how how all these things
each of those house puts you into this
like mode of procrastination where
you're stuck forever right and so
instead of doing thinking about the
house i figure out who are the people i
need okay if you look at any good
superhero movie what always happens
right
usually there's like this person there's
you and this little cape on you so
you're a superhero right but most
superheroes can't save the day maybe
it's just cause i watched justice league
and avengers and everyone recently but
if you look at all the superhero movies
when they got a big vision what do they
do the justice league calls their people
in the avenger group gets they get the
hulk and they get thor and they get all
the people they get all the who's around
to help them to dominate this vision
okay so for you as the entrepreneur if
you're not careful you can get in this
procrastination mode where you instead
if you start saying who are the people i
need to build this this vision then it
gets you off this procrastination or it
gets you moving towards your vision and
some of you guys are sitting back saying
russell i don't have any money to hire a
todd or hire the people i need to get my
vision so i have to learn it because i
don't have any money i'm broke right
well i got good news for you guess how
much money i pay todd to build click
funnels
at first zero now he gets paid a lot of
money right but what happened we
partnered on it he saw the vision he's
like oh that vision's awesome i went in
i said cool let's get together let's do
this thing and we both got together
we'll put our skin our time our effort
into it and then we build a thing right
and then like i don't know how to buy
ads so then john on my team i'm like
john here's the vision john's like i'm
in boom he started buying ads and then
we start bringing all our avenger team
together to go and conquer this vision
so for you you've got to figure out
what's your vision who are the who's you
need to execute on that vision and then
bring them together all these your
superpowers partner together and then go
and create the vision that way you won't
get stuck in procrastinating which is
where most people get stuck and i always
tell people like entrepreneurs usually
don't
it's not that they that they don't have
the vision the problem is they either
run out of time or money before they
ever get to the vision it's because of
this they're trying to figure out the
house the house on every single step of
the path when you do that you never
actually get to the end goal so
take this take your computer turn off
youtube turn off all these things aren't
helping you and start focusing on who
who are the who's i need to dominate
this rule number four regain your focus
with tom bilyeu what steps can i take to
bring my focus to the one thing i'm
working on while blocking out all else
all right
so
the real key is you've got to learn to
compartmentalize so what i do to begin
my compartmentalization is i create a
list
of all the important things that i
should be working on
i put that list in order this is very
important getting good at prioritizing
is an art form it is critically
important that you get good at that art
form and as you begin to break things
down and put them in order now you can
tell yourself hey this is what i should
be working on right now so rather than
trying to digest all the different
things that have to be done it's i'm
focused on this one thing right now and
my only job right now is to focus on
that thing and so by not letting your
mind wander and this meditation is very
good at bringing your focus back to the
breath which teaches you to bring your
focus back to whatever so i've got a lot
of things many things competing for my
attention but i know what my important
things are i'm working on the number one
thing right now let's say and so up this
is my entire world and if i find myself
wandering i bring myself back now part
of the reason that i can invest so
heavily in that is because i have the
belief that that's the most effective
way to work so
since behaviors follow beliefs you want
to make sure that you put that belief in
place which is true by the way that you
can do
everything that you want to do just not
all of it at once so everything has to
be done sequentially you can't do
everything at the same time and this is
why you have to prioritize things out so
if we know
that multitasking is actually a myth and
that you can put people in brain
scanners and what you're seeing people
who seem like they can multitask what
they're doing is called rapid switching
so they don't have what i have which is
high switching costs when i get in a
flow man i can go and go and go but
if i try to bounce back and forth
between things then i pay this high
price and inefficiency between the
switching costs of moving from switching
from that task to this task so i focus i
stay on one thing i have them in order i
know what i'm working on i remind myself
that i only have one job in that moment
that is to work on that thing i know
that that's the most efficient way to
work and i know that i'm good at
prioritizing things so it becomes very
easy boom boom boom and then you just
hold yourself accountable to actually
doing that
practice makes perfect you might have a
difficult time in the beginning start
meditating if you need to to train
yourself to come back to the breath over
and over and over and then you can just
apply that to whatever you're working on
come back to the project
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five prioritize things
with gary vaynerchuk there's a ton of
stuff that i procrastinate and i think
i'm a procrastinator but i what i think
i also am is always leveling up
whatever's most important and
prioritizing it in real time team can
tell you here
i bet you steve's favorite inside joke
is demayo
can somebody get me to make little get
me demaio
watch this
uh this will answer your question
perfectly vaynernation uh because the
truth is um
i do procrastinate but i'm adjusting to
the reality of my life at the moment i'm
living it so
if something is super important
yesterday
i can literally decide that it's less
important in an hour predicated on what
comes into my inbox or the meeting that
i'm about to have right after this and
so the reason i think it feels like i'm
not and so much is getting accomplished
is my pants are on fire for the thing
that i deem most important at this exact
moment and that is how it works over and
over where's the mail and over i'm
trying to stall here and over and over
and over again let's go to the next
question we'll get back to the mail
oh curious okay here we go don't go
drock leave all that don't edit that
i'll be pissed
now tell the vayner nation
how what's up world
uh
tell the vayner nation how often i'll
send
an email that will say
now this is top priority versus the next
day this is top priority and then you
get crippled by the notion of hold on if
like literally what i'm like no no this
is the number one priority in my top
priority is the way it is tippy top
tippy top tippy top
uh yeah probably every time you're on a
flight there's probably about 15 emails
that come out and then you struggle with
like what's tippy top versus number one
yeah unless you say to be top priority
is that the new context
that that's what you've been using for
the month all right so maybe it'll
change the new year thanks man and
that's what happens right matt
my admin you know he has to struggle
through what is tippy top priority of
the moment because it might change
tomorrow so as long as you're executing
something every day as a tippy top
and priority item then you're moving the
needle and sure something might have
moved from second most important to
fourth most important the ninth most
important alex you're dealing with this
right now a lot of things that you would
have dealt with like biz dev was like
the most important you can't get a
minute from me because something has
caused it to become the eighth most
important thing versus the number one
important thing and then like it just
there's a lot of serendipity
steve's been waiting for this top six
things at wine library for four days i
found a minute i decided it was tippy
top primer of that minute and it just
works that way at all times rule number
six hack your brain with brendon
burchard let's talk about
procrastination right now and just have
a conversation about what it means
you know procrastination
basically means that you are
not doing what you know you need to do
when you know you need to do it it's
putting things off because in the short
term
it's easier it's more comfortable it's
more certain it's more pleasurable to be
distracted or to indulge yourself doing
something else than it is to sit down
and do the actual work to create the
outputs that matter when they are needed
and i know that every single one of us
procrastinates me too so it's okay
the issue is can you set yourself up so
you do less of it
i believe you can so let's talk about
procrastination in this way three brain
hacks number one
simple
you're more likely to do something
if you have already
prepared and stepped it through
you're already more likely to do
something if you already prepared and
stepped it through what does that mean
it means if you want to
not procrastinate on
monday sunday night i want you to sit
down and do this simple little thing
project plan
i know it's not sexy please don't make
fun of me right now it's not sexy i know
it's not sexy and it will change your
life forever
the day before
the days in which it's required that you
really get stuff done i want you to sit
down
and project plan i don't mean tomorrow
write down your to-do lists that is one
element of project planning but i want a
bigger picture i want you to be thinking
about the big projects that you have
coming up and i want you to have written
out
these steps that it's going to take the
big steps that we'll take to accomplish
this project and this project and this
project with a timeline for each of them
and then work backwards from that to
create tomorrow's to-do lists
but here's what's funny
if listen to this if your mind can't see
completion
if your mind
cannot see completion meaning you don't
know the path
you don't have clarity
on the path to fulfill or complete
something if your mind can't see the
steps
your heart will ask to pause
if your mind can't see
the project through the completion
your heart will ask to pause
even if you're the most passionate dream
oriented amazing high performer in the
world
but you yank away someone's clarity
you know no goals no growth
no clarity no change
and so if you find yourself
procrastinating
it might not even you might be like but
brandon i hate myself i procrastinate
and i even know the next three things i
should do i go not enough
knowing your next three steps
is not enough
your mind needs to see
all the steps through to completion and
that's what we call project planning
it's not super fun but it's saying okay
this is the big project here the big key
activities the big buckets of activities
that would have to happen to get it done
here's the timelines those big buckets
have to happen okay then these big
buckets of activities those have to be
broken down into tasks
and then into ultimately daily to do's
and if we don't have that like it's just
hard to act when you don't have a
complete picture
right you're kind of like uh
procrastinating let me give you a
metaphor
you know
they've timed people
about how long it takes them
to complete a puzzle so if i show up at
your house and i give you a big
puzzle box and there's 400 pieces in it
and we set it out on
your table
and we watch how long different
time periods takes to complete it you
know the fastest most productive time in
which people are putting puzzles
together
the last 20 percent
if you've ever done a puzzle right you
might walk by it three four times for a
couple weeks you don't do anything you
put a few pieces together but as soon as
the picture becomes a little more clear
guess what you do
you hunker down
and you complete it don't you
that's what's going on procrastination
even if you see the first couple pieces
it's just like if you can't see where
it's going
your heart will go
pause
i'm unsure
i'm scared
i don't know what to do
that's just how we think
right that part of our brain that is
trying to protect us
that part of our heart that says i want
to do good i want to care for other
people and do things with excellence all
of a sudden those are compromised when
we don't do the most basic thing
so if there's an important project
you've been procrastinating in do
yourself
the greatest gift i can give you today
and that is tonight sit down with your
journal and step it all the way out
even if you have to make it up even if
you're like i'm not sure this is
actually the big activities it it's not
about having the perfect project plan
it's having one that is completed at
least the knowledge you know now
because then your brain go okay let's
get into this and keep making this thing
better but your brain won't get into it
if you haven't project planned so this
is really important what i do to avoid
procrastination each week is every
single sunday for me that's my sunday
review days sunday work days i'll sit
down and i'll literally step through the
entire week of all the major things on
my
email or on my to-do list
i'll think about the bigger projects
and i'll just kind of step it all the
way through
and guess what
i enter the week
more engaged
more joyous and confident because i know
what the heck is going on
so if you keep procrastinating i promise
if it's not lots of worry or it's not
you know lots of randomness it's you
haven't seen it through yet
other brain hack very related but a
little different and more immediate and
you'll love this one so number two is
this and it's so basic but i'm gonna
test you and see how often you've been
doing it and that is
visualize
remember i said you won't do it if your
brain can't see it step through well
here's specifically what i do to make
sure i don't procrastinate i literally
visualize
and
affirm what i'm about to go do
so
if it's sunday and i'd say okay
you know tomorrow
in the afternoon i've got all these
things i can procrastinate because i'm
the only one holding myself accountable
and i could say well you know what um
let's see here
how would i avoid that
i will sit down
and i'll do this 20 30 minutes a day
visualizing
the next day
or that morning i'll sit down and
visualize the day and i'll just step it
through i'll say okay
let me see myself
going into the kitchen
getting my little green tea
going over to the office
sitting down at the computer
opening up that blank page
happily typing along
sensing
and feeling those great emotions of
doing my calling as a writer
let me feel the power and the joy of
finishing a great day of writing
let me imagine myself going to dinner
getting to sit down with my wife
and saying honey here's what i did today
i wrote this part of the book let me
hear see and feel that interaction with
her happiness and her joy that i'm doing
my path
let me imagine myself going to bed that
night happy
that you know what
i did what i'm here to do
now i don't know what your calling yours
or what you feel like you should be
doing but
for me that simple little activity of
just literally walking the entire day
through not just one thing
i do this with with mega athletes all
the time i say listen i don't want you
to just imagine the fight
i want you to visualize yourself on the
way over to the arena
i want you to see visualize yourself
getting laced up i want you to visualize
yourself on the walk down to the ring
entering the ring your first feelings
walking around the ring the sense that
you will have as you're in that fight
that sense that you have when you're
getting beaten in that fight and how
you're going to feel and respond to that
because visualization is not just
happy-go-lucky it's also like okay
see yourself what do you do when there's
a struggle
so i for me okay what do i do when i get
writer's block how do how does the
brendan dealing with writer's block
deal with that
and i'll see it i'll imagine myself
getting back at it
and i'll see it through how does it feel
when you win how does it feel after the
win how does it feel at the end of the
day how's it feel when you finally lay
your
head onto your pillow and go to bed
that is a full day visualization
on the things that matter the most for
your productivity
and i want you to do that at least
either the night before
or the day of the morning of and the
last piece is the other brain hack don't
forget
that not only do we need order not only
do we need the creativity and the
visualization we're also social animals
so i want you to socialize your agenda
with other people
socialize your agenda with other people
what does that mean
well it's just the same you know at this
time of year a lot of people are trying
to lose some weight or trying to go to
the gym and what's the first advice
everyone always gives them because it's
proven by science to work over and over
and over again
get a workout buddy
because if you've got a workout buddy
you'll show up
it's harder to procrastinate when your
name
your integrity your relationships
are on the line
and so you need to tell people
about what you have to do
like you'd probably be annoyed hanging
out with me because i like if we went
out to dinner i'd probably tell you like
10 things i'm going to do tomorrow
and i'm not telling you that because i
love to talk about work
i know if i speak it
it will become more real the next day
if i don't affirm it and share it with
other people it's just in my head
i'm just not going to be as productive
and i do know without question this is a
big issue for a lot of people
they're
stay-at-home moms
they're work from home entrepreneurs
they're you know the senior leader in
their company
who does a lot of status things but they
don't themselves get to talk through a
lot of things
and i can't tell you how important it is
to speak through the reality that you
want
right
these things you could certainly do on
your own but if you share these things
with other people and you socialize that
agenda
all of a sudden you won't procrastinate
because you know that you've put it out
there other people are going to hold you
accountable
or even just more
sometimes talking something through
makes you want to do it more
literally they found in psychological
studies just speaking out your goals
makes it more likely that you will take
consistent action on those goals you're
literally just speaking it and they've
even done it where they took out other
people they just made someone stand in a
booth with a microphone and speak out
what they were going to do they were
more likely to do that than if they just
kept it in their head and didn't speak
it so if you're like brandon i got
nobody who believes my dreams i'm like
well i bet you have a friend and you
could facetime them or skype them and
talk through it
it is so important for you to speak
through
your dreams
than you could probably ever imagine
and a lot of people keep that stuff to
themselves
because what they're worried how they
look
so now imagine all these things
colliding on the opposite
you're worried how you look
so you don't tell anybody so you're not
socially accountable and you have no
social cheerleading you're worried what
other people will think
so in your brain you go well
if other people are going to think i'm
crazy why even do this i mean that's a
risk
so i might look stupid if i do
so now your brain goes
well why even imagine this for yourself
anymore
then your brain says well if you can't
imagine it for yourself anymore why
would you even plan it
and if you can't imagine it you can't
plan it and other people might think
you're stupid
why don't you go find something else to
do like netflix or shopping or hanging
out or indulging yourself in some other
hobbies that aren't relevant to what
you're trying to do aka let's
procrastinate
because we're worried
you see all these tied together
so the brain hacks
are to set yourself up so that you have
more confidence
and routine and structure
going in these are the three ways as a
recap project plan night before week
before day of i don't care but the if
you can do it the day before it sets it
mentally in your brain and you have a
little more confidence in it definitely
visualize the night before or day of
all the time and the last piece is
socialize it
you've got to start sharing your
thoughts your dreams your agenda what
you're gonna do with other people and if
you do those three things your brain
will be more optimized and more likely
to get in the game and get stuff done
rule number seven match skills with your
challenges with j shetty how many of you
have ever felt that you don't have the
best skills in an area and the challenge
feels really high
chances are if you've experienced that
you end up feeling frustrated or stuck
and disappointed in yourself and that's
one of the reasons why you start
overthinking and procrastinating you
don't have the skills you have a
challenge or a goal that set really high
and now you feel overwhelmed and
overburdened by the height of that
target that you just give up and stop
working
sometimes we have the opposite
experience where our skill is really
high but actually we haven't looked at
our challenges we've been doing the same
thing over and over again we've been
repeating the easy win and in that
situation we sometimes feel bored lost
or confused we feel like our life
doesn't have meaning it doesn't have
purpose and there's nothing exciting or
thrilling about the work that we do the
author goes on to say that flow is
achieved when our skill
meets our challenge
so when we really want to experience
that flow state being in the zone
feeling that momentum feeling that
energy thriving we have to make sure
that our skill and challenges match are
we feeling frustrated and stuck because
our skills are too low and our
challenges are too high or are we
feeling bored because our skills are too
high and our challenges are low
in either case we want to focus on
either increasing our skills or
increasing our challenge
that helps us focus on the area that we
actually need to have an impact and we
stop wasting time with all the
distractions so now instead of
procrastinating and overthinking we
start focusing on a list of things that
can help us improve our skills you have
books
coaching mentors communities courses all
of these are phenomenal ways to start
learning now if you're someone who needs
to increase your challenge your
challenge can be increased through
networking i remember when i used to
speak or get invited to speak at
colleges and schools i love that
experience i still do it today whenever
i can but at one point i realized i
wanted to stretch my comfort zone then i
started working with corporate companies
because i really wanted to help
organizations build new models of
thinking today i work with so many
fortune 500 companies and enjoy the
experience deeply but i also wanted to
extend my challenge beyond that i
started speaking on stages i started
speaking at my own events what i found
is that you can extend
your challenge by increasing your goals
or targets
or by changing the scale or the depth
sometimes we challenge ourselves by
trying to affect more people do more
things and sometimes we challenge
ourselves by going deeper in the areas
we're already in and finally a new way
of challenging yourself is a new
industry when you think about someone
like michael jordan who went off to play
baseball or you think about steve jobs
who went into movies and pixar and
animation people have challenged
themselves across industries when
they've truly mastered their field so
the question i want you to answer is
this instead of procrastinating and
overthinking do you need to work on your
skills or do you need to work on your
challenges and you'll know where to
start rule number eight find your
passion with sadguru if you're
postponing something
you're obviously doing something
that you don't want to do
if there is something that you really
want to do will you postpone it or prep
on it
hello
do you see somebody is waiting for
someone they badly want to see
only 10 minutes
in the 10 minutes they will look at the
watch 25 times
why they want to pre-op on it
you're doing something that you don't
want to do so you want to postpone it
i'm asking why the hell are you doing
something that you don't want to do
no because if i do this i will get that
i will get that
that's not the point
there's nothing to get in this life
there's really nothing to get in this
life
either you lived this life in a profound
and intense manner or you did not
what will you get in the end
if somebody dies in the agricultural
college do they bury them or
fire them
how is it what's a tradition
burying is good for agriculture
because human beings make good manure
so in the end what will happen to you
and me
they will either bury us or burn us
that's all will happen in the end you
think something else they'll give you a
price
nothing will happen in the end
only thing is the process of life how
wonderfully did you live
that's all there is
so if you are doing something really
wonderful
do you want to preponet or postpone it
free upon only so you must find
what is it that you really want to do if
you find that one thing you will always
prepond everything not postponed rule
number nine build your self-esteem with
john assaraf i have a question for you
did you know that procrastination is
keenly associated with lower self-esteem
let me explain
think about this
if you knew you couldn't fail and you
knew that whatever you did
would be right
wouldn't you just take action and get
the results you want would you
procrastinate
would you wait until it was perfect
would you wait until all the pieces were
together before you took action for most
people the answer is no
and according to the latest brain
research if somebody has
self-esteem issues where they feel that
they need to have it perfect and they
need to make sure that every piece is in
the right order and together
that is going to activate their stress
centers in their brain and if the stress
center in the brain is activated
chances are that they are not going to
take action they are going to
procrastinate and
their lack of motivation is not because
they don't want to achieve their goals
and dreams they have their lack of
motivations because the motivational
circuit gets shut down annual number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is learn and implement with
dean graziosi i know the people that are
gonna make it i can literally see it in
their eyes i could feel it and the other
ones i worked so hard while we're
together to see them that they have
a formula that makes sense first for you
to pay for speed for you to listen to
podcasts for you to read books you're
ahead of 98 of the world who just want
more they want to make the money they
want to be the leader they want to win
the game but they're not willing to
practice when no one is watching so i
teach my kids i've been telling you guys
the same thing i teach my kids you want
to win at the games
practice work what you win when no one's
watching right no one's watching these
people at a mastermind but when their
business exploded their new company
starts so they get the real estate deals
like oh how they get so lucky they
didn't get lucky they cut a check
but once you gain the wisdom once you
feel it once you know a direction
there's a couple of things i'm just
going to be completely transparent about
stop searching for six million opinions
sometimes we get great advice
and we don't take action so we look for
more advice and we don't take action and
we look for more advice we read a new
book find a new podcast find a new guru
find a new expert
because we're
we either don't take action at all or we
dabble or we we go in half-assed so it
doesn't work oh that didn't work what
dean said so let me try with bob and
then joe and then tony and then brendan
and we just keep going and going and
going
i watch it i see it sometimes another
person another variation and this is not
not knocking you in any way this is all
about me getting you to take action live
the life you want another person who
hides in action with i need to learn
everything i need to know all the rules
i need to read everything about it i
need to study i need to get five courses
and and listen to 50 podcasts and they
go and go and go and their
inaction is caused by
needing more information
like if i study more if i have more
wisdom it's really just your
subconscious finding a way to protect
you by not taking action because when
you take action on something new on the
opposite side of that could be a failure
could could be something that didn't
work could be scary so your subconscious
says no no let's just get more data
let's get more data then we'll take
action no
you're just scared you're just fearful
and that you have to acknowledge what is
holding you back is it fear is it worry
is it is it you feel you you've created
a story in your head that says you know
maybe it's not the right time or maybe i
should feel safer maybe i should be
happy with the life i got [ __ ]
[ __ ] your subconscious is protecting
you so the formula that i wanted to
share with you today what's on my heart
because believe me i wanted to get up
this morning i wanted to stay in bed
this morning but i needed to take action
because i'll feel better i'll serve my
clients better my team better if i go to
the gym if i if i get them that momentum
so here's a little formula
knowledge amazing you need it following
others who have uh conquered the game
before you and are crushing it you need
it you must get in a mastermind
learn from people playing the game at
the highest level possible masterminds
and group training have literally moved
the needle for me more than anything in
the history of the world knowledge when
it's thought through when it's practiced
when it's in play becomes wisdom you're
learning wisdom from most if you go to
the right mastermind the right group the
right mentor so you got the knowledge
you got the wisdom you're surrounding
yourself with with information that has
been proven to work so what's left
it's taking action
that's the formula knowledge plus action
equals results what i'd love for you to
do today is an action audit
are you really putting into play what
you are learning are you just dabbling
are you over preparing causing you to be
crippled that you're not taking action
and start using whatever it takes to
ethically bribe yourself to take action
listen today
i didn't want to get up
simple going to the gym at 5 30 my alarm
went off at five i really didn't want to
go i'm tired you hear my voice you never
hear my voice have a little tiredness
i've been on the move i've been in a
plane every day i've been teaching every
day talking every day but what i did is
i i hacked my own brain i said if i
don't go work out today
how will that make you feel i didn't
work out yesterday morning excited to
get up at five o'clock and jump on a
plane
so you didn't work out yesterday you're
not going to work out today how that
make you feel when you play with your
kids later what if you're tired when you
when you put your pants on there's a
little muffin top on your pants it
doesn't matter what it is i just use
whatever it takes to get me to take
action if it's you saying hey in five
years from now i'm still gonna be at
this job i'm still gonna be stressed i'm
still gonna have these bills i'm still
not gonna live the life i want i still
can't retire my parents or take care of
my kids or put money away in savings or
buy the car i want or have the freedom i
want whatever it takes get disturbed
because if you get disturbed
it'll cause action or if the opposite be
to serve say if i do this i get to dream
i get to get the house i get the life i
get more freedom i get more control in
life all i'm saying is use whatever it
takes in your toolbox whether it's being
disturbed or whether it's getting
excited to take action because knowledge
listening to me listening to books going
to masterminds without implementing it
is just wasting your time
many of us have issues with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burned out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been so i hit a bottom
recently with this productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways i was
then blessed i said a prayer i said i
need some help with my brain fog and i
need some help with my productivity
issue and i that day got an email from
the dr oz show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
dr dr mike dao and me and mike had been
in touch many years um for many years
just because he hadn't been author we
were published by the same publishers
and mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day i'm like thank you
universe you're giving me exactly what i
need i go on dr oz with mike and i'm
backstage with him and i'm like listen
i'm feeling so
chaotic and i'm multitasking so much and
my i feel like i've got brain fog and
i'm forgetting things and he looked at
me says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multitask the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day to make a list of the five
most important things that i need to do
that day and not do number two until
i've completed number one and then once
i complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if i
don't get through all five in one day
i'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever i left off i'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
i did it i started to just be very clear
about the five things i was doing in a
day i told my team i made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and i made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
i'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
going to do five things i have been more
productive i have created more i have
been more intuitive i have been more
inspired and i've been more creative so
i i've had such success doing less and
back in the day what i would have done
two weeks ago before i started doing
this practice i would have tried to do
30 things in a day not really completing
any one of them and feeling completely
stressed out and
and not on top of anything not complete
in any area
so as a result of making the commitment
to five things a day i have completely
changed how productive i am by doing
less
so i give you this as an opportunity to
be less stressed out to get more done to
be more creative to
take a little bit off your plate and to
try to really be complete a task before
you move on to the next one ladies i
know that you are much like me those
multitasking ladies out there you
probably have a million browsers up stop
it
bring down those browsers be more
conscious and be more mindful of the
ways that you show up for your
productivity and the less you do the
more you will create think big
act small
think big you got a big dream a big goal
a big mission some big thing that you
want to get done that's where we love
being as entrepreneurs right we love
thinking about the big
future and what we could build and it is
amazing and exciting but it can also be
overwhelming it can be stressful it can
be hurtful to our own self-esteem
because
tell me if this happened to you you've
got this big idea and big goal
and it's exciting to think about it but
then it also becomes scary and it
becomes impossible and it becomes
something that someone
like you
can't do and then we get overwhelmed by
the details and then we can't
do anything about it because it feels
too big and to execute it we need a team
and we need venture capital and we need
investors and we need better people
around us and we need more skills and
all of these doubts and insecurities
creeping does that sound familiar is
that you
certainly is me
you know i want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough
and anytime i think
even close to that scale it's instantly
well how am i going to do that
how am i going to do that i'm nowhere
close
and so the thing that's really helped me
is
think big
but then act small
because the biggest thing that most
people are missing i'm missing you're
missing is just momentum biggest thing
we're missing is just we're not we're
not doing enough
because thinking big
and having a big idea is amazing but
that alone is not enough you have to go
you got to do the work and we're so
worried about
the work being perfect right you're so
worried about the first thing being
amazing
and it won't be
and this is a hard lesson that i learned
when i was
in my early twenties in my first
business and we lost a forty million
dollar deal because i was trying to be
perfect
and i spent the whole summer working on
this perfect plane
and i lost a deal and i'm a recovering
perfectionist
and i think
saying you're perfectionist really just
means you're afraid right you're afraid
of
it not being good enough you're afraid
of launching something and people
seeing it and judging you or you're
afraid of launching it and then not
seeing it nobody caring right we're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
both at the same time we're afraid
so the answer is to do something
immediate action i've been helping
people in my movement makers program
get going on youtube and now on tick
tock
and the amount of
indecision that people have around
creating their first video
right what should i wear what should i
say what should my opening line be what
should my thumbnail be what kind of gear
should i use what kind of camera what
kind of microphone what kind of
fill in the blank right
all the things that just prevent you
from taking action
where the answer is just film honestly
like just just get something up like i'm
filming this video on my phone walking
down the street
i didn't sleep that well last night and
getting some sunshine on my face
and just pressing record and going
and i'm doing the best i can with what i
have
and that's what you need to do is just
get it started because the best
plan that you can come up with right now
is nowhere close to the plan that will
help you win
you know the plan that you come up with
right now is not going to be the one
that works
because you don't have all the
information and so the idea that you can
plan
what the end looks like
and the path to get there is impossible
and so we spend our best energy
planning and thinking
instead of actually doing
that's a big problem
and so it starts with
okay you've got this big idea awesome
now what are you going to do today about
it today there's a couple of hacks that
i want to share with you that i think
can help so the first is a two percent
difference and the two percent
difference says
instead of planning for a hundred
percent you you work on the first two
percent so what is that first two
percent that's all you need to work on
what's the first two percent
so if you're thinking about
youtube or making a tick tock you're
thinking about a health journey you're
thinking about
whatever it is for your business that
you want to launch what's the first two
percent
i just started building momentum
so you know if you want to make a
youtube video go film a video just tick
out your phone and film a video just
like i am right now you want to get
started take part cool same thing
flip your flip your phone the other way
vertical
and start making your video you want to
start a health journey cool
you know we get so stuck on
figuring out what the perfect workout is
going to be right you ever done this
well am i going to do hit am i going to
do cardio how many weights are going to
do my am i going to am i going to hurt
myself do i need to hire a trainer what
new equipment do i need to buy
you know we just get stuck in all this
planning mode instead of doing
just do anything just go for a walk do
five push-ups
you know do a couple burpees whatever
whatever comes to mind it doesn't matter
what you do
it's a matter that you're doing
something that's the big difference it
doesn't matter the specific action that
you're taking what matters that you're
starting to build some kind of momentum
that you're doing something
that's the most important thing because
if you
get up and you do something every day
you're gonna find that you start making
some tremendous progress towards things
and so two percent difference is to
teach yourself that you go from an idea
to some kind of immediate action that
we're doing something right away on it
we're not planning for a hundred percent
but we're going for that first two
percent the next thing is just expect to
suck at the beginning
you know we expect to be great
out of the gate for some reason you
expect
your idea to work you expect that you're
going to have the skills or you expect
you're going to create something amazing
you won't just expect a second to start
it doesn't mean that you suck as a human
it just means that you don't have the
skill set yet and that's okay that's
normal and that's totally okay that's
fine
go back and watch my first video it was
pretty embarrassing go back and watch
anybody's first anything and it sucks
it's normal
so if you expect to be great
and then you try something and you can't
do it then you feel really bad about
yourself but if you expect it to suck
and then
and then you're just anything above
complete
terrible
sucking
then you're good then you've won
and so
apply the two percent difference
and then just expect to suck to suck at
the start and then you keep going
so for anybody there who's afraid to
take action who
you know you have these big ideas big
goals big dreams big things you want to
do
but it just seems so out of reach and it
seems impossible and it seems that you
can't do it and it's never going to work
you know and you're stuck in
overthinking
over planning over
estimating over just over over over just
stuck in your head
and it's crazy how quickly we can go
from being excited by something
to then almost instantly overwhelmed by
it
you know and so you need to have the big
dream you need to have the big goal that
that should get you
out of bed and excited it's like yes
this is the change i want to make in the
world amazing
and at the same time you need a
incredibly small action plan just to get
going
because you've got the great heart and
the big dream and the big mission the
only thing you're missing is momentum
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to hear
brian tracy's best advice on
productivity check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there mr brian tracy how we doing brian
i'm doing great how are you
i am amazing thank you for making the
time i know you have a busy day shooting
a bunch of videos for your channel and i
appreciate you carving out some time for
us today